Am I too tall?
For most of its history,
America's population has been younger
than other nations. As a result, America
has been a nation of risk takers who
have quickly found prosperity. But in
recent years, an aging America — led
mostly by the baby boomers — has made life
more difficult for young Americans. As a
result, American institutions have
stagnated. A population that is aging is
not necessarily alarming. But with age
come more invasive and burdensome
regulations in many walks of life. In the
cases of housing and employment, older
Americans have slowly created policies
that protect their investments, whether
it be in property or a career. Stringent
zoning laws and employment credentialing
have caused younger Americans to spend
more time getting dubiously-useful
degrees and certifications, and taking on
more debt, delaying marriage and
childbearing, which in turn is making
America even older and more bureaucratic.
Simply put, when the population becomes
less agile, so do its foundational
institutions. Eliminating unnecessary
regulations and barriers in many sectors
would create an America that is stronger
and more prosperous for everyone.
So what do you think about this? Do you think
America's institutions have become more
rigid and inflexible? Let us know in our
poll. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.